hi I'm chef Spike Mendelsohn from DC and
we're making a Nashville hot chicken we
score the chicken because it's going to
help cook quicker and more evenly and
you won't over fry your chicken and dry
it out I could see people making this
all year round really I mean you know if
you're having like a backyard party this
is great because you can get really
sloppy with it it's really simple to
make it's like four ingredients at the
end of the day so you can offer a really
delicious recipe for the group that's
coming over or your family and you get
to hang out and have fun and not be
stressed so it's like one of those those
go-to things that you know you can shout
out in your back pocket who are those
things the stand up has to be hot sauce
that you're gonna put on it and the
bread and butter pickles the cooking has
always been a staple in my household
especially my grandmother my sister and
my mother always cooked cooking was
something natural is never really
something I had to learn you know just
something that was part of our family at
good stuff we take classic American fare
and and just make them delicious and I
mean listen it's chicken
it's a buttered Pennsylvania potato bun
and bread pickles I mean you can't get
any better than that look a little bit
of hot sauce oh yes